hello everybody and welcome to another
episode of my 100 account flippin series
and today were actually on to episode
number 5 already crazy this will be
bringing us up to 25 accounts however
first up we have to go have a look at
the results from last week so I speak
was reasonably good I do need to make
some changes regarding some items in my
account let's start off and start
selling some of the items so to start
off one item that I really need to
change up is the rune essence it buys
pretty quickly however you can see that
I really have not sold nearly enough in
the week think only sold at third are
not even probably close to a quarter of
the amount we're gonna since I got in
one weekend this week even from one
account I got like another 100 - 50k or
something to sell off which just cannot
be sustained so it's really not a viable
item so I think I'm just gonna remove it
one other item I need to switch up it's
also the maple logs it does so offer
quick enough however I need to reduce
the amount of accounts because this we
can get in another like 700k maple logs
I think I've only sold like a third or
maybe 2/5 or something of them so I need
to reduce the amount of maple log
combined however otherwise item is
pretty sound so this week I had a couple
issues come up and one of them is that
some of the prices ended up fluctuating
price fluctuations really are not in my
best interest either a the price goes up
and I don't buy any items in the Alpha
slot or be the price goes down I pretty
well instantly buy out my entire offer
within a couple of days and then I have
to hope the price goes up which it can
work out however I would prefer the
price to just stay stagnant stay the
same and just get a 1gb margin for one
that's way harder to keep track of if
I'm getting a 2 GB margin on some of it
and some of it not and it's just a bit
more stressful I have to go put on the
offers again there's just a lot more
work now this is mostly a symptom of
kind of stretching away from the highest
volume items however because I'm doing
this I am getting more in profit than it
was before it's just a bit more work the
basic elemental runes continue to
underperform pretty heavily I really
don't think it's worth investing in any
more accounts into them I'm just getting
lower and lower returns every time not
sure if it's because of the videos I'm
making or just just dumb luck or I know
no is
they're really not working out pure
essence continue to be good however this
week I did see a pretty noticeable
reduction in the amount and buying in
each account not sure exactly what the
reason is but it is definitely
noticeable so after adding up all the
totals this week I made pretty close to
7 mil so it was higher than last week
however a bit disappointing that it was
not not that much higher honestly it's
only next year I have 600 K over last
week but still good our total is 6.8
mill still very good for completely
passive income but you can see that the
overall performance of the items over
last week is definitely less so next up
I'm gonna have a look at my spreadsheet
and updated with the new information as
well as replace a couple items on a few
accounts first up I need to completely
delete the roon essence because it's
really just not working out I think I'm
gonna reduce one offer slot of the maple
logs as well just to get a little bit
less coming in but first up let's go
have a look over the spreadsheet and see
which item might fit these new slots
alright so we're into the spreadsheet
here so let's have a look we've gone
ahead and inputted the offer so we've
gone ahead and added our total from this
week which is actually 68 for 8 and
total bringing up our all-time profit up
to you Breeden pretty close to 20 mil so
this month we got eighteen point five
million profit I've listed down to kind
of a science if I were to not be
recording the video in producing a video
because that does take a bit more time I
could probably only dedicate an hour and
probably only like 20 to half an hour
every week if I were to just kind of
update my offers not add on new accounts
so that's a very high profit per hour
you're probably looking at 10 to 20 mil
for your time invested which is amazing
one thing that's also slowing the
process down that is related to being a
youtuber is Authenticator [__] you guys
have to put in the Authenticator well
maybe one or two accounts but now this
week I'll be adding on to 25 accounts
that's 25 accounts with Authenticator do
they pretty well have to type in every
time I don't know why it says it's gonna
remember it for a month but it doesn't
[__] ever do that so every time I
have to type in an Authenticator code
which is very time consuming so let's
have a look at the per count totals from
this week I really need to actually
replace the old data without a function
because currently is updating with the
new item totals which is not good
because it's actually changing the data
so we'll have to actually go ahead and
type in the number maybe we're actually
divided by the proper number here is
given us some incorrect item data from
the previous week so if we have a look
at the basic runes did it all right I
think that's pretty so much last week
considering we only added on I think
water and earth or something like that
water rooms are actually doing quite a
bit better than the other ones but it's
probably averaging around 75 or
something like that
now the body we actually did
surprisingly well at a hundred and
thirty three K per account which is
actually quite good it's fairly
substantially better than these other
rooms plus it actually sells off very
quickly too so I think I'm definitely
gonna bring the body rune up to five to
make it on level with the rest of them
and then we can kind of see on the fair
playing field which one is the best
moving down here to the other items
we're going to look at a feather it's
still pretty decent 71 k per item which
is still relatively good compared to the
basic runes I'm not sure what a good
benchmark for a good item would be I'd
say a hundred K plus is very good I
considering on how many accounts you
have of course but I think that's a good
benchmark now an important one here is
the pure essence I'm pretty sure the
poor can't hold his gun down because
last week it was like 220 plus or
something like that and yet send 166 now
I'm not sure if that's actually because
of added on more accounts or it has to
do with some other factors let's say I
brought this down to nine which is what
it was that last week and we'd be
looking at about 258 so maybe I've kind
of capped on this one so I don't think
I'll add on any more pure since this
week iron arrows did very good two
hundred and sixty K and I'm pretty sure
actually the iron arrows right now can
sell for a two GP profit which is even
better that's at 1.4 mil potentially
from that item thereby really quickly so
this is probably my best item so far
this week so I'm gonna add on more iron
arrows for sure the only problem with
this is the price has been fluctuating a
bit which makes it a little bit more
tentative to do maple logs are actually
quite nice as well I haven't in some
issue sell them as item off though as I
mentioned earlier some fortunately I'm
gonna have to reduce one of these offer
slots I think willow logs off actually
quite quickly all but within the first
couple of days and 108 caper items
pretty decent it's a little pricey you
think it's seven or eight
GP each yeah but I think I'll add on
maybe one or two more with a log this
week
rune essence it's good but doesn't sell
unfortunately I still have a ton left
from the week before and now I have
another 125k which will probably take
like a month to sell his rate so I'm
just gonna have to remove this item
unfortunately so we'll find something
replace it
next up the jug of wine not amazing but
it's actually a very cheap item so it's
pretty economical in that sense so I may
add on some in the future
last up the vial of water actually I'm
missing about 100k of this item because
I ended up buying it and selling it back
for the same price so none of these add
vials of water were actually profitable
because they tanked by one GP however
I'm gonna continue to do it and just
hope that the price day is more
consistent in the future so I'm go ahead
and update my graphic maybe remove the
of rune essence and then I'll go ahead
and add them some new accounts and
decide what I'm going to put them in
turn we're back at it again we're gonna
run five new cans through tutorial
Island and should I customize my
character at all I guess maybe it'll
make him look a little bit less like
BOTS and it's not worth it
alright let's get started okay so we
were done tutorial island that we
started at 4:17 or done at 4:35 that is
quite good that's 120 minutes actually
very quick and now we're onto the main
line that will go ahead and start the
quests alright we're doing consistent
once again this guy really just needs
help all the time every single guy who
comes by he needs a hand with his cakes
there we go one quest point down and
we'll go ahead and do gum diplomacy and
dorks quest all right there we go dorks
quests done that nice and easy another
quest point completed I've decided just
to continue doing this process I did
look into a bit if I actually
technically need to have the quest
points and kind of yes I would have to
drop tracing which we need counts which
would be a pain in the ass and
definitely not worth it all right there
we go gum diplomacy done that would go
ahead and run to the ground change and
transfer over some money I think today
we're gonna do three mil per account
access pretty much what I have left and
at that point there's no point of having
any money left over cuz I'll have to
wait and earn some money for the next
week alright so we're gonna add on a
couple new items this week these are
actually just suggestions right from the
comment section so I'm reading them
Reserve we're trying one account buying
an empty jug for one GP we'll see if
that
so worth a try next up a new item as
well is going to be the fishing bait
combined for three and it's just nice
and cheap and I think the fishing bait
is promising so we'll go ahead and do
this on a couple of counts I think and
I'll last up for count number one we're
gonna do a jug of wine it did perform
pretty well last week so I think I'm
gonna add on maybe a couple more of
these guys so in total I want to add on
to body runes - willow logs - iron
arrows three feathers two jugs of wine
three fishing bait and a welt one jug
all right on account number two we're
gonna add on iron arrows feathers and
jugs of wine nice and cheap items so I
can actually have pretty big stacks
all right account number three is gonna
be willow logs a fishing bait and
feathers will of logs are kind of
expensive but still magic 875 K in there
all right count number four they're
gonna be iron arrows of body rooms and
the fishing bait again pretty nice
stacks over 200 K and that'll definitely
be good for at least one week and the
count number five is gonna be full of
logs as body rooms and the feathers so
I'll have to see how this week
progresses I still need to go ahead and
change up two items into slots on
accounts so go ahead and do that quickly
and then we'll go and update the
spreadsheet so back of the spreadsheet
some go ahead and update or buying off
your slot tab here as well as just
finish up this so for week number five
we're gonna have 25 count so we'll see
what the profits gonna look like then
here's what we ended up adding on I did
go over it already
and we also changed out the rune essence
for another jug couldn't think of an
item plus didn't really feel like
transferring money over oh so we and do
2 times the jug this we'll see how that
works out
all right so we added on two jugs three
fishing bait two more jugs of wine sold
out bran total up to four three times
feathers bring us up to seven feathers
two times iron arrows bring us up to
five iron arrows two times little logs
bring us up to four willow logs and two
times the body runes bring us up to five
body runes
okay wait no no we're good we're good
we're good zero rune essence okay cool
bring us up to twenty five accounts and
seventy five offer slots so we'll just
go ahead and well we'll leave it at zero
for now just in case we change it in the
future plus it would mess up my entire
diagram here so we went ahead and
actually put in numbers here so now when
we go ahead and update
the amount of offer slots we have a one
actually affect the per count total so
we'll go ahead and move this over all
right guys that's about it I hope you
enjoy the episode number five I guess
we're on already crazy so if you're
enjoying the series really appreciate if
you toss the video like if you have any
ideas for items I should do or things I
should change some people suggest that I
should improve my spreadsheet which is
probably true but what exactly would you
improve about it
layout or function zone if you have an
ideas leave a comment thanks for
watching guys appreciate the support and
I will see you in the next episode